sending alex berdugo and raffy debras
running for their lives
sort of at least getting clear of the
diamond
so they could do their job
which they do so very well and the
grounds crew's really been tested
nathan avaldi on the mountain for the
red sox start number 14 of the year for
the hard throwing right-hander seven and
three with a 4-1-1 era and simeon to
climb in
they get terrific power out of their
lead-off maze hit 15 home runs
batting 294
002 pitch coming to the american league
player of the month for may
a little pop-up loop toward right arroyo
going out and he's got it over the
shoulder
christian at second base tonight one
gone
so we pop up into shallow right field
caught by the second baseman simeon up
there at 294 by the way he has a 26 game
road hitting streak which is the toronto
blue jays record
here's another one of the nemesis this
is bo buchet
he's seven for 15 in this series
he's at 281 13 homers 39 rbis he leads
the league and runs scored with 56.
here's the pitch and he swings it it's a
soft ground ball to the shortstop
bogarts has to wait on it fires and just
does get him on a close play he can move
down the line
so a couple of quick outs already a
better start than yesterday
and here comes vlad guerrero who's homer
in the first three games of the series
he's the triple crown leader 3-1 pitch
and he swings it it's a hard grounder
diving stabbed devers throws him deep
behind third got him by plenty
what a play by raffy it took a double
away from guerrero
he wasn't showing his sprint speed down
the line there but he think he thought
he had a double
and raffy made a beautiful backhand stab
on his knees down the line and made that
very long throw from the edge of the
outfield grass one two three after a
half an inning toronto nothing but
coming up alec manoa gets the call
tonight for the jays the right-handed
rookie 1-0 a 3-1-4 e-r-a in three starts
[ __ ] hernandez will lead it off for the
red sox hernandez hitting 230 on the
season just one for 12 in the series
that was a two-run single yesterday but
long after the matter had been decided
on the scoreboard blue jays were way out
in front
one-own a fastball is popped up on the
right side of the infield rowdy teles
the first baseman tonight makes the
catch one down number two hitter for the
red sox is alex verdugo 3-2
and verdugo lifts it to left field
guriel back and has room right in front
of the monster verdugo retired two down
so two up two down for manoa in the
bottom of the first and now the red sox
dh jd martinez hitting over 313 home
runs on the season
a slider popped up shallow right field
and comes to oscar hernandez and it's a
one two three bottom of the first for
alec manoa and fenway and it brings up
brando graychick
who's hit in three games in this series
all three six for 14.
2-2 pitch
swing and a miss it was an underwater
cut
and nate picks up his first k tonight he
gets gretchen so now christian arroyo
the former first round pick of the
giants back in 2013
the o2
sliders swung on and missed he strikes
arroyo out
the red sox will leave a man on
so now the number nine hitter bobby
dalbeck
runner not going and a 3-2 swing and a
miss got him with a great slider over
the outside corner for the first down so
now one on two down for verdugo
hit a high fly ball to left field that
was caught by guriel out there 1-0
verdugo drives one high and deep into
the left field this one hit well guriel
back he leaps and he cannot get it it's
off the wall and off his glove here
comes [ __ ] the shet's throw to second
not in time rbi double for verdugo
and the red sox lead it one to nothing
martinez with the flyable to right field
in his first inning at bat
the
1-0 and this ball is lined to center
field but it's right at randall grichik
and that'll be the inning but a run on
two hits for the red sox and they lead
one to nothing at the end of three
glad guerrero junior next all for one
pachette runs and avaldi never looked at
him pitches called a strike on the
outside corner he wrung him up i mean
buchette broke before evaldi moved he
didn't even care and they struck him out
i think he distracted guerrero he was
distracted by that
so two on now with two out for randall
grichik the 1-0 pitch is drilled high
and deep into right field verdugo will
have room though ball not carrying
tonight alex is there he makes the play
crisis averted jays get their first hit
and the first two base runners but they
are stranded we go to the bottom of the
fourth
one nothing red sox
top of the sixth inning one nothing red
sox and rhys maguire the catcher
hitting here he's all for one the two
strike pitch swinging a miss he blew him
away with a 98 mile an hour fastball so
two hooks and then heat
nate has his third strikeout one away
one down here's simeon he's popped him
up two times
trying to dot him
away oh and he did
he struck him out
simeon will debate it
caught looking two-way
verdugo's a really good
opposite field hitter and we've seen him
do a fair bit of damage to left field
against the blue jays in this series
and how about the slider to get him
swinging and manoa is fired up
jd's gone over two he's flied out to
right he's flight out to center
02 and martinez went around at that
slider and roberto ortiz the home plate
umpire made the call jd martinez and
saying elise go down to first but
ortiz rings them up and that's
back-to-back strikeouts for manoa about
to throw his 90th pitch that will match
the most that he has thrown in a major
league outing
as he faces ander bogarts who has flied
out and walked look at that slider
bogarts with a chase
it has been an incredible two and a half
months
for vladimir guerreros he lines one to
center field
[Applause]
and that is down for a base hit for
vladi to lead off the inning just the
second hit of the night for the blue
jays and they've got the tying run on
here in the seventh
and there are two one with nobody out
for randall grichik
round ball there's denver's gunning in
the second one on the first double play
taylor made
guerrero down to third but two gone do
it nasty flat guerrero at third and
rowdy teles to face josh taylor who's
been on some kind of run
taylor delivers
swing and a miss hey struck him out
nasty slider
and taylor does it again
native aldi in line for the win taylor
strands another inherited runner we go
to the bottom of the seventh it's
stretch time at fenway one nothing
simeon is over three 26-game road
hitting streak on the line
swaying in a miss yes he went strike
three
one gone
so barnes is two-thirds of the way there
to try to secure this victory for the
red sox but he's got a deal with vladi
guerrero had a base hit to center his
last time up
breaking ball hit high indeed to left
field
tie game
the best hitter on the planet right now
has done it again and it's a brand new
ball game at fenway
what can you say other than wow
another curveball and vlady
it's amazing what he has done devers
will be the hitter raphael tonight is
single he's hit into a double plate
and he is grounded out to the shortstop
swinging a high drive center field deep
bridgette going back back by the wall
it's off the green and here comes
verduco with a winning run
raffy devers walks it off a wall ball
double